onde a índia não é hora da escolha de
pessoas fantásticas como harris poll
olha o ator do que a gente isso é um
motivo de que o cdf hoje foi uma criança
muito curiosa e entendeu muito bem com
as coisas funcionavam
o legal é que sai fazia ao chamar
atenção
tom e eu espero que mais chama a atenção
um grupo de pessoas se reuniu avançar
algo relevante o rangers venceu o sábado
de visita
o engraçado dessas histórias os
integrantes das habilidades e
competências muito diferentes daquelas
diferenças eram fundamentais a vitória
da rússia é um negócio e participava e
ajudar os funcionários da sociedade no
brasil na áfrica
o produto estava em todas nesses casos
eu hoje não podia perceber muito
fortemente era que as empresas mais
inovadoras que mais produzir o resultado
é daquelas empresas que tinham à sua
rotina diferente de hoje 1º é inovação é
importante
segundo ele o sistema de trabalho tem
construído gera inovação
e o terceiro é de trabalho sobrevive a
uma cultura diversão e de comissão pela
inovação
a gente agora novidade mais interessante
que seja por um segundo
na época o telefone de novo a 10 o que a
gente quer mas esses grandes anúncios
nessas grandes novidades elas são fruto
de uma série de tentativas o que
acontece todos os dias
é o que a gente vê ouvia era steve jobs
na frente falando apresentando um novo
produto o ipad iphone ipod ou seja
qualquer coisa a gente não viu os
engenheiros ainda trabalham durante
horas dias anos consiga idéias parecem
ser uma grande é os filmes mostra
oficial do dia sobre nós
cheguei um dinheiro a mais inteligente e
talentoso
a altíssima qualidade e que esse rapaz
uma louca pra ouvir deus finalizou
razão tinha o respeito da equipe pessoas
gostavam dele
meses depois eu ia lá na difícil viu
o time paraense marcelo dias depois nada
eu trabalho saúde e em feriado pra ele e
aí pensando navio não qualquer coisa
quando voltei lá e realmente tinha saído
porque foi uma auditoria anual fora
seguir as regras e fazer o correto das
pessoas
não sei vocês mas a intenção aqui eu
tiro disso é que eu não quero é ter uma
extensão da próxima vez que alguém tiver
lewis funcionar em área que eu vou fazer
eu vou esconder o nosso problema dela
vamos lá ao chão uma data na parede é é
um anjinho e até aí eu falo
e aí eu queria compartilhar com vocês a
questão da cultura a gente queira
promover de pessoas boas intenções mas
sentidos e as histórias de heróis dessas
histórias residuais da empresa não
valorizam as pessoas reforçam o que
acaba acontecendo é que as pessoas ficam
refém das histórias são contadas duas
pessoas pessoas trabalham na linha final
e trabalhar menos da metade
é interessante entender isso isso não é
culpa de vocês por mais que às vezes as
pessoas querem fazer vocês vocês pensam
dessa forma só em todas as pessoas são
cubos sistema de trabalho você salvar um
lugar onde as histórias são contadas
histórias de obediência de omissão de
manda quem pode obedece quem tem juízo
mas é muito difícil que você possa
exercer sua criatividade você vai lá e
aí eu resolvi essa história toda de
vocês contam com nenhuma casa seria
sistemas ruins
ao falar do programa você as pessoas é
que se você tem uma pessoa que trabalha
com você essa pessoa não faz gol é legal
é hoje uma forma o caro sistema os
municípios pessoas curso qualquer uma
das sete bilhões de pesos
você vê o caso com seu sistema de
trabalho com o im ele não vai só a
grande sacada desse negócio pagando a
gente pensa o seguinte percebe que você
mandou uma pessoa e eu falei isso aqui
você quer levar uma pessoa a fazer o que
você precisa seja bem essa lógica das
organizações está muito equivocado
alguém nasce invadiu a responsabilidade
de alguém está fazendo o seu cliente
precisa é ele e verso como
empreendedores hoje diariamente ea
grande maioria deles quando dizem que
dinheiro não vou fazer dinheiro à sua
mesma forma como a mídia vai comentar o
que as pessoas querem dar às suas
atribuições maior lucro
a gente quer fazer isso mas nossa
expressão as baixas nossa humanidade
pessoas resolver o meu problema e não
encontra
e aí começa a apostar na regra seja
acham
conforme o que eu quero
se o chefe da ordem e se ele faz é
errado
a coisa pode acontecer e isso é ruim a
gente precisa fazer é o líder precisa
sair da zona de conforto e paz a
observar e um local de trabalho
conversar com as pessoas
ouviu que está acontecendo são elas que
sabem efetivamente precisa mudar
elas estão em contato com 13 todos os
dias ou pelo menos estar mais próximo
dele e ele precisa agir e fazer
diferente
nada acontece sem ação
e aí pra mudar esse sistema mudar essa
cultura gente desempenhar novas
histórias e valorizar novas pessoas
novos heróis estão agindo da forma que
ela diz
valorizando o cliente isso é fundamental
agir diferente
eu falo para vocês é quando você chegar
ao trabalho segunda-feira
percebam quem são as pessoas estão
agindo diferente tentando melhorar o
sistema está vários lugares
estas ações que realmente valoriza e
compartilha as histórias que vocês
querem compartilhar entre os grandes
o ted é muito legal conta disso ele
valoriza e dá rosa aquelas histórias
como o da onu
da mesma forma vocês precisam da rosas
em que as pessoas nem a presença de
vocês que não queria mudar a empresa
construiu uma empresa tão bem
essa é a grande sacada a gente precisa
da rosas pessoas ouvir as histórias
diárias histórias que vão gerado por
exemplo de comportamento que a gente
teve essa talvez seja a voz dessas
pessoas valorizar as pessoas ouvidas
pessoas
a gente vai conseguir pará o ecossistema
dessas organizações errado ou mais e
aprender com olhos e aí quem sabe
renovar o boys